either hi so you know from our brief
waiting conversation that I did not look
you up and you did look me up but now I
know that you're interested in space and
also in business that's both are true so
talking about global business I'm
assuming that that's working on the gap
they say the wealth gap if you will or
the business gap is that is that sort of
an accurate statement or you're just
interested in any business that's global
what do you mean by the what what do you
mean by the gap well you know we're
richer they're not right that gap well
yes in the sense of my view is that if
the whole world is getting richer than
almost everybody's getting richer so the
theory is to stimulate global growth
worldwide so it's all growth good growth
most growth is good growth okay so you
are you concerned about pieces of the
pie who's getting pieces of the pie how
they're investing to get them of course
I think equity is a huge issue and the
way in which the system in many
countries including our own is working
today is not actually delivering equity
though I have it is is John Perry Barlow
still here Joe he's a Syre lized that
actually John Perry Barlow is the
psychedelic Robert Reich if you if you
if you look at John and see Robert right
actually it's actually Robert Reich in
disguise it's actually the psychedelic
Robert right right because of course
that's his great preoccupation is
economic equity right well the project
that I work on is trying to do knowledge
equity which is why it's interesting to
me that they paired us to speak because
I've spent a lot of my life in what
we're now calling the global South
trying to figure out how to give away
more because it bothers me that that
lack of equity and I look at Africa now
it's very hard to get people to invest
in Africa because they're in the early
stages still they're still you know
cleaning the swamps up and stuff right
and yet I look at China investing in the
sudha in
or places like that and and it's really
an interesting question like that's a
pretty pretty longtail investment there
you know well the you work for Wikipedia
and and I have said for a number of
years now I think Wikipedia is the most
important anti-poverty tool the world
has invented in a very very long time I
think the impact of what you and your
colleagues Jimmie's of a good friend are
doing is hard to overestimate if we're
in a global knowledge economy and
knowledge is where the real source of
wealth not resources and minerals and so
on then the fact that any kid on the
planet now with web access and that's
now on the order of two to four billion
people means that they have access to
essentially all the world's knowledge
for free you have changed the game as
fundamentally as anybody can change the
game well yeah as a movement we've done
that that's true it's a it's a huge
movement you know I spend a lot of time
thinking about futurism and humanism and
how they're linked because there are
plenty of future so that will tell you
that the world is ending and you know
blah blah right but but the idea of
doing something about it I have this
totally strange conversation at Ted
earlier this year with with a famous
technologist who has decided he's done
the math and he's decided that there's
no point in trying to save the earth in
any way like it is just it's a it's a
zero-sum game and it goes something like
this
if everything is money if energy is
money then if you buy products that are
green they're more expensive therefore
you're netting the same you know expand
the spend ature and and besides which
were just a blip in the geological
history of this planet so we might as
well burn faster and on that basis he
drives a Humvee or something like that
right and it was so depressing to have I
mean if you look at what's happened by
way of human progress in the last 250
years and you compare how we live versus
anybody a century ago two centuries ago
three centuries ago you look how many
people live well today compared to even
50 years ago or a hundred years ago and
how many are likely to live well fifty a
hundred two hundred years forever in
three hundred years if you look at the
long-term population
forecasts of the earth from the UN we
could be down to two or three billion
people with an average global income at
the bottom okay so that the lowest paid
person in the world would earn in real
terms and allowing for inflation share
the equivalent of a hundred thousand
dollars today that's just simply the
current trends continue for the next few
centuries so we're on the right track we
have been on the right track for the
last couple hundred years and the
pessimists have got it wrong the
optimists keep getting it right well one
of the things I that drew me to
Wikipedia and that I love about Jimmy is
how he talks about the nice people you
know people who contribute to Wikipedia
are the nice people there they have they
have some generosity in their souls and
they aren't they aren't troubled by the
fact that they're not being monetarily
enumerated for their work right well
look it really works Wikipedia is a
perfect example of the network economy
working and that is that networks only
work by virtue of what you put into them
not what you take out of them networks
do not exist because you extract things
networks exists because you put things
in and we now live in a global network
economy that would not exist where
people not creating websites not
creating opportunities for mutual
interaction and learning and capability
so in fact when we move from the
resource economy in which you got the
steel or I got this deal but we both
can't have the steel you have the oil or
I have the oil we both can't have the
oil but we can both have the knowledge
we can both participate and communicate
but there was a time in human history
where suppression of knowledge was the
way that you controlled people right
that was the whole church thing right so
even they can't get away with it anymore
is it yeah interesting isn't it so you
know you you seem optimistic I'm very
optimistic well that's good you know I I
my kid is 20 years old I expect him to
see the next couple centuries how
important do you think freedom in the
sort of abstract senses not the not the
W Bush kind of freedom with the real
freedom because we spend a lot of time
thinking about free culture free
knowledge you know it's not just that
its culture and knowledge it's free and
free as and you can use it too and you
don't have to pay anybody anything it's
nice if you put a little sweat equity
into it you
maybe write a couple pages but that the
reason I ask is because there are people
in Taiwan who do nothing but figure out
how to tunnel through the Chinese
firewall to get Wikipedia translated
content into China because it's it's
censored there by the government and
it's it was really dangerous if you're a
Chinese national read it to read it but
people still do because they're so
hungry for knowledge I think a lot about
that like is it even possible will there
still be repressive regimes oh they'll
try but the eventually they lose they
can't but knowledge not in the economic
sense wants to be free but I think
you're right I think it flows and it's
unstoppable a Stewart and I had dinner
with Mikhail Gorbachev a few years after
he left office here in San Francisco he
had a small dinner and we got to ask him
an interesting question which was why
did the Soviet Union end and he said it
was very clear was the satellite dish in
the PC when our people could see the
rest of the world and we couldn't
control what they believed game over the
real heroes of the revolution were Ted
Turner Steve Jobs the guys who and
George Soros who opened up the
information game for the Russian
citizens and then the game was over and
you know the fastest-growing Wikipedia
right now is the Russian one not
surprising we don't even know why I mean
at Wikipedia we or Wikimedia Foundation
we're not quite sure why Russia is the
winner right now but people are just
giving them content constantly you know
English Wikipedia has plateaued a little
bit and I apparently you know three
million plus articles is a plateau but
there's but there's lots of languages
where they're still tiny and and we're
gonna do a lot of evangelism of the next
five years to try to get some of those
global South countries to start building
their own content and because there's a
built-in resentment of things that come
from the US in a way you know people
want to own it's a position they should
they should they absolutely should I
mean the mission is imagine if everyone
in the world had access to the sum of
human knowledge in their own language
absolutely so well and I look I think
one of the most painful statistics that
came out of the Arab human development
report that was published a few years
ago
was that out of the several hundred
thousand books published
in the world every year 400 are
translated in Arabic yeah yeah you know
it's a culture making its system self
systematically stupid and you know I
think Wikipedia is a very important
vehicle to breaking that which culture
is that you think I mean there are the
Arab world is a billion people right
right and no I know the Arab world
Islamic the Arab world is mostly around
the Gulf and North Africa it's a few
hundred million people you know I did
Peace Corps time in Morocco one of those
Arab countries Ghana huh a score Ghana
what is it about people who did Peace
Corps I mean I did it because I believed
in in service but I didn't want to carry
a gun and Vista was already gone so you
know right out of college signed up for
the Peace Corps me too
Jannik you sixty-eight so I mind was a
little later than that but not very much
and and mitai learned in Peace Corps and
it was a crash course is it's it's what
you do as an individual it is not this
organization that you work for because
frankly it wasn't that an exemplary
example in in in Morocco they weren't
really doing the right things but the
individual volunteers were often doing
side projects that amounted to the right
things it was really an interesting
experience that way actually by that my
experience was similar to I actually
resigned because I thought we were doing
the wrong things yeah yeah he asked to
do the wrong things however my
conclusion was that actually the
greatest value of the Peace Corps was we
all learned a lot I don't I'm not sure
we did very much the countries we heard
we worked in but boy did we learn a lot
and the impact of former Peace Corps
volunteers on the United States has been
enormous there's an enormous number of
PCBs that have served in public service
in academia and so on in
entrepreneurship where they learned what
they learned coming out of the Peace
Corps so the Peace Corps was a very
important human development tool for the
United States you think it was it was a
liberal change training ground of some
kind
perhaps so Sargent Shriver when it would
a sneaky guy yeah yeah cool
well do you have any questions for me
well first you touched on something
which is I think very important and that
is the cultural diversity within
Wikipedia I said it's a very important
human development tool and then you also
the observation of having multiple
language Wikipedia's beginning to
develop a rather more than 200 now more
than 200 yeah how will that play out you
know or are we going to find ways you
know I'm one of the people who believe
that language and culture affect your
view of reality how you see what you see
is literally a function of your language
and history and culture so as as
Wikipedia emerges and develop I'm an old
student of the foundation and the
Galactic encyclopedia like people warden
I'm a science fiction fan and the
Galactic encyclopedia or encyclopedia
Galactica I think is what it was called
was it was an important tool or are we
going to see some kind of coherent
mutual learning process out of all of
these embedded realities in the
Wikipedia you mean are we heading for
the for the Babel time well in a
coherent way I mean a mutual learning
way in other words will I see for the
first time how a person who think who
who speaks Bhutanese thinks in Bhutanese
sees reality fundamentally different
because of that well I think so so all
the big search companies and big tech
companies use our databases to try to
make their machine translation better
better and better and better it turns
out you always have to have humans
interact and tweek at the end but we're
I think it's it's the place where
simultaneous translation by machine is
going to happen or where all the
learning is going to happen behind it
because there's a huge database it's
like you know and it's publicly
available you'd have to break any
privacy laws to use it and so they all
kind of land up to use it Google's done
when Microsoft's done went in and what I
think we get out of that in the long run
might be what you're talking about I'm
not sure how we get the spin on it
though from a from a like practice point
of view German Wikipedia is the second
largest Wikipedia after English and they
review every edit before it's committed
every single edit is moderated so it's
not like English Wikipedia where you can
change something and see it on the page
right away they do that in the interest
of correctness and that in itself says
because it's very German right and they
only have 900
or so article think they like can't
break through the million barrier there
it's been very hard for them that's why
do think that there's a lot of cultural
context to how the different ones happen
sometimes Google did this project where
they gave a bunch of translations just
certain countries where they were trying
to perfect their translation tools and
some of the countries are like thank you
and others were like I don't want that
you know it was very interesting to see
who was interested in taking the
translation and who wasn't and some of
it I'm sure had to do with how good the
translation why isn't whether how it was
big work to fix it but some of it was a
national pride thing like you're an
American company and we want to fix this
ourselves so but is there any
exploration within the Wikipedia
community of tried to kind of map the
concepts across we had an anthropologist
speaking at a linguistic anthropologist
speaking along now about a year or so
ago and was studying a language in
central Brazil
whose perceptual structure was
completely different time was different
they didn't really have anything beyond
a couple days in the past a couple days
in the future they didn't have numbers
beyond zero one many or zero one too
many so there were many elements of
fundamental concepts that were very
different across the various Wikipedia's
all these definitions ideas are highly
cultural and glyphs Tingley dependent do
you study those well so we don't as a
foundation but one of the things about
Wikipedia is its because it's a huge
publicly available data set researchers
just love to tiptoe through it we
there's constantly interesting research
and we try to help them by giving them
dumps regularly so that they don't have
to crawl through the live site and you
know right we hear a lot of interesting
stuff though I mean I know what you're
talking about about language supposedly
ancient Greek had no word for blue like
skies were purple and you know think
about like they didn't have the whole
spectrum because it hadn't been studied
yet so it's fascinating how it might
change your perception of everything
well the history I mean if you were
writing the history of the Middle East
from the point of view of say the
Persians you might write a different
history than say from the point of view
of the Egyptians well that's this is the
thing with China the reason
they're censoring us is because of the
Dalai Lama and Tiananmen Square of
course those two things don't exist they
didn't happen right well the Dalai Lama
exists but you know he's not the guy we
know right so he's the punch on well no
they're right Emmy was a bad guy and
they did a good thing by getting rid of
him and you know so and we have versions
of that right in English Wikipedia where
there's a lot of editors hundred
thousand editors they spend a fair
amount of time trying to erase bias so
there's an article and it's it's a
fairly extensive article about
intelligent design just like there's one
about evolution and they try really hard
not to take sides it's hard I mean we're
humans right but the intention is to
create a compendium of knowledge without
bias and of course we have liberal bias
according to Republicans every so often
they they scan the bios of the you know
various senators and then we get this
note wanting us to change stuff and DNC
does it too it's really as a marketing
tool I guess you know for your
individual self Wikipedia becomes
interesting but looking again looking at
the English version against everybody
else's version and and what the
differences are and how it's going to
affect the future is fascinating to me
the idea that people won't in the future
have to learn English in order to get
access to knowledge it's really exciting
because what I did in the Peace Corps
was teach English and which those people
in Morocco needed about as much as you
know a hole in it in their bucket right
and what they needed to know was how to
grow more food so they wouldn't have to
buy their food from us yeah I was doing
science and math it was still not
another Wikipedia subject governance so
you are guys you guys are now in effect
the arbiters of knowledge the
universities were the arbiters of
knowledge before but of course they had
departments academics they had peer
review they had all these mechanisms
developed over hundreds of years by
which authority and truth were
established
what's governance like in Wikipedia it's
interesting so so I work for the
foundation and I work on the engineering
side I'm the CTO so we kind of create
the vehicle right that the content is
all created by volunteers which is
amazing to me like we don't write any of
that we've commissioned that it's all
written by volunteers they came
over time with a governance structure
for English Wikipedia which is the one
most people mean when they ask the
question that you know tries to be fair
with in human experience it tries to
recognize good work and offer more
responsibility as it tries to be a
meritocracy but human nature being what
it is there are little attempts at
fiefdom and all that crap - the good
news is that it's because everything is
visible all the edits are visible all
the decisions are pretty much visible
there's plenty of opportunity for people
to question is more democratic I think
than some other forms you can do there
are certain pages that are so
overburdened by edit that we have to
periodically turn the pages off because
the opposing factions on Obama want to
say he is an American or yes there he is
and there he is and it just gets boring
so we turn it off
but yeah the governor's question you're
right arbiters of knowledge but it's
important to understand the foundation
doesn't set those rules the foundation
exists to make the website continue to
run its the actual contributors that set
those rules and that's open source right
there
right I mean fundamentally Wikipedia is
the triumph of the internet and open
source in a way so open knowledge open
culture the fact that everything's going
to be visible all of your actions are
visible get over it right there is no
privacy if knowledge is political as
many people would argue then can you
really be as neutral as you claim I'm
not sure humans can be it's a really
good question we'll leave that one for
the next guy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you